i still haven't watched all you watched
it you finished it i haven't yeah i
haven't yet
i never even watched breaking bad
i like the i like the scene where mike
tells walter to put his dick away that's
in breaking bad right that's not
breaking bad oh why do you love this
i don't know it's just
you know you know when you discover like
a video and you end up watching it like
five times a day you know that's that's
that's the that's the point you're
taking away
you just walk past like god's house on
the wall ginger [ __ ] but it's your dick
away walter
why are you laughing so much
i like the scene where the guy says you
can call me sauce
i'm very glad that breaking bad memes
are still in like it's been it's been
how many years and breaking bad things
just do not die i think it's caused a
better it's because of better medical
schools we're doing wonders yeah but all
the memes are from breaking bad still i
know like they're all jesse and you know
there are some soul memes but it's
apparently all jessie anymore
it's kind of getting to the point where
breaking bad memes are kind of getting
to the point of like spongebob you know
where
it just it just lives on in memes and i
don't know why the memes have just lived
on like
you think that they would have exhausted
all of the meme material because this
show is like how many years old but they
still like the memes keep refreshing and
they keep getting like good new memes
and i don't know [ __ ] how um but yeah
like better call saul i've heard amazing
things about so good sydney will not
stop raving about it it's so so good
yeah you've got to watch so it's like a
spin-off of
prologue prologue okay it says before
but it's about uh the lawyer following
his life you say loyal as if i know the
character i've learned you're so good
man i
it's like the ancient meme of like soul
and it's like it's so good man like it's
held up like as good as like it's as
good as breaking bad yeah i've heard the
so so good i thought the final season is
like nutty it's insane it's so good and
at the time of recording there's
literally one more episode out in like a
few days yeah but it's it's so [ __ ]
good well joe you finally watched the
boys right
watched as in the first two episodes oh
okay the first two episodes but i i
highly
um
why haven't you continued it
i just haven't really had the time to
sit down and watch it yeah
season three was amazing
yeah but like so far first two episodes
so far has been [ __ ] amazing i just
love carl urban and everything he does
it's great yeah he's like one of my
favorites still i still gotta watch
season three oh she's so good is it the
best season so far you reckon
i think
for me yeah probably i think out of all
the seasons it's probably the best one
because i i think i enjoyed season one
the most i've only seen the first two
seasons uh season two i heard season two
is a bit of a slowdown right there was
some really slow moments in season two
season one was just like every episode
was a banger season two uh had a good
beginning had a good ending i think the
middle was a bit it was a bit air um
still waiting to watch season three
because sydney wants to watch
all of the boys together again and i'm
like can i can we just start off
she's already seen it huh she's already
seen yeah she's already seen the first
two seasons but she wants she wants to
refresh her memory because uh that's a
lot of time to put into refreshing your
momentum like a recap on youtube or
something just go to movie clips youtube
channel and just like watch all the
clips you do not need that it's so
excessive it's it's like watching tv
series you get nerfed when you're in a
relationship and you start watching
together you actually get [ __ ] nerfed
you get this joke yeah because sometimes
you just want to watch your head by
yourself but like i think like she would
get less offended if i like slapped her
mom then if i started the boy season
three by myself i'm i'm the opposite
right now because rocky just caught up
with all of the um stranger things like
seasons and i'm just like can we start
again from season one and she's like
[ __ ] you no
watch it yourself you little [ __ ]
i'm like all right [ __ ]
yeah because you watched the crown
together with [ __ ] as well yeah yeah
that's great i love that series i'm
still waiting for the next one i don't
know sometimes i just i just i just like
watching things at my own pace yeah and
especially now there's time is limited
you know free time is limited and when
when i feel like watching the boys or
when i feel like watching this tv series
or re-watching season one and two you
gotta you gotta show that's a big extent
you've gotta shut that down yeah that's
gotta you gotta you gotta stop that
right now yeah no no no
this is not how we're doing tv once
we've watched something we've watched it
we can't agree on it which is why i
haven't started season which is the sole
reason why we haven't started season
three
no we're doing this
but i'm married now connor i'm married
i'm yeah that means you have more leeway
to say yeah yeah yeah
what are you gonna do divorce me
should be like we're not doing this
we're not watching
am i the unreasonable one here i think i
think she's right so why'd you get
divorced oh
well she wanted to watch this she wanted
to watch
one of the boys yeah
that counts as like diabolical
but you also watched uh invincible right
yeah yeah
that was oh my god that's such a good
series like i knew i was gonna enjoy it
because of all the memes that i saw and
just from like the concept of it because
like you know we were talking about
marvel before right and like i am so
much better i am definitely in that camp
of i am so [ __ ] sick of the just
trophy superhero yeah and then finally
in there when i read about the concept
for invincible i was like oh [ __ ]
finally yeah you know this this seems
way up my alley and i watched it and i
remember i think it was either you or
you or both of you were saying like yeah
it's it's it's like a really violent
series yeah and i was watching through
episode one and i was just like
there's not really nothing really
violent about it and then after the
credits you know that the scene after
the credits i was like oh oh
oh oh oh oh that's when i was like oh
this is something special yeah i was
like oh okay now we're talking hell yeah
and then yeah i binged it in like two
days while i was in l.a and it was
[ __ ] amazing such a good show such a
good show i finally i finally got to see
all the memes in in in context i finally
saw the think mark think meme and i'm
just like oh that's where that's from
okay
it's it's like it's such a good feeling
where you watch a series where you've
only consumed it through memes yeah you
finally see that me moment and you're
like it makes so much sense now
i get it that was me with the entirety
of spongebob because i didn't grow up
with spongebob because we didn't have
nickelodeon when i was growing up right
and i only actually sat through and
watched all of spongebob like last year
or the year before how much of spongebob
is there there's a lot like five or six
seasons but like oh
no no no
there's like [ __ ] 30 is there yes
but only the first four seasons matter
okay
okay so that changed a lot because
anything like that
after season four is [ __ ]
we just went through i watched all of
spongebob
spongebob is there 13
that was like a whole [ __ ] evolution
backwards that was that went from four
to now no i will i will happily go and
learn how to moonwalk there with how
much you [ __ ]
i will happily [ __ ] devolve my
statement because like i uh like once i
started watching you straight evolve my
statement i'll go monkey's statement on
that because honestly after like i
started watching season five and it just
like i don't know what happened it's
like with kind of like with the simpsons
where it's like i don't know if they
like changed writers or something like
that like the uh the creator left oh the
crater left okay yeah right
his name oh [ __ ] uh [ __ ] yeah i know
you told me he left and like nickelodeon
took it over right but they took it over
anyway but i think he had no say in it
anymore yeah it's like a lot of the
the charm was kind of gone yeah
yeah like it felt like spongebob and it
was spongebob but like the jokes just
didn't hit anymore yeah and i was like
oh it was just like a sudden change all
of a sudden as well and then aki was
like yeah honestly anything past this
point is just kind of [ __ ] also like
spongebob became like the face of
nickelodeon so they like couldn't go get
as risque in some i think so i i don't
know they they rely on spongebob a lot
like i think like nickelodeon's
programming is like majority spongebob
like if yeah like i don't know sorry
about this cartoon network then he
[ __ ] plays teen titans go when i was
in america i want to watch cartoon
network yeah it was just teen titans go
all the [ __ ] time and i was like 9pm
and i want to watch something and i'm
like what is this this is [ __ ] yeah give
me the normal teen titans but that's why
like the early spongebob seasons were so
good because it almost had like a red
and stimpy vibe to it where it's just
like it's some of the jokes i'm just
like oh yeah children should not be
confused
it's very adult what made you want to
just watch spongebob because i finally
got to the point where i'm like i'm
consuming all of these spongebob memes
because they're [ __ ] everywhere like
you know like like breaking bad they're
just like timeless memes and i'm just
like i kind of want to know what the
[ __ ] is happening like i want to see
these memes in context right i like how
you like thomas memes it's like but you
dick away walter
timeless
time
this means
and so like you know i was just like i'm
finally gonna sit down and just like
because again like i didn't grow up with
nickelodeon at all so i had the same
thing with avatar the last day of bender
as well yeah like i didn't grow up with
that [ __ ] so like three watched it
like three years ago i finally watched
it because at one point like everything
was on netflix yeah so i was just like
oh [ __ ] it it's on netflix i'm just
gonna binge the whole thing yeah that
was [ __ ] amazing
well like because i haven't even i
haven't seen spongebob yet so none of
the memes make any sense but yeah i've
never watched it i i mean i've watched
one or two episodes fully of spongebob
again i didn't have [ __ ] nickelodeon
as a kid because i didn't have sky tv um
because i if if it wasn't on channel
the first four channels then i probably
wouldn't have watched it unfortunately
because i didn't have cable um so i
never got the chance to watch spongebob
and so i i only know about it through
memes yeah and i've always assumed
they're not meant to make sense
you know it was on watch tv oh it was on
welsh tv with the welsh dub really
mm-hmm they are
well how what's spongebob squarepants
and welsh i don't know i can't remember
i remember i said it really weird though
and i even as a kid i was like i think i
think this the english one is way better
than this
but like what i really appreciate about
spongebob is the fact that like a lot of
the jokes that didn't end up being memes
i think are even funnier than the ones
that did end up being memes because it's
like again it's like it's it's like the
first couple of seasons of spongebob was
so good because it's like some of the
funniest jokes are some of the subtlest
ones yeah where like kids wouldn't get
it but the adults be [ __ ] cracking up
about it because it's like it's a little
too clever for it to be just packed away
as a children's show right i feel um
yeah and it's great it's [ __ ]
hilarious i love spongebob yeah
i can see now finally after watching
like the the funny seasons
absolutely that's really good yeah okay
the original episodes are really funny
really funny yeah i might well how did
you end up watching it because i don't
know how you would watch it here in
japan uh it was on one of the streaming
platforms i think but i think recently
now they took it off because i think
nickelodeon's trying to do what disney
plus is doing